richie tress who also goes by richie and
tres won over
shiloh couturier 13 year old girl who is
ranked 133rd and uh
border global ranks which are based on
performance and skateboarding
competitions trust by comparison sits at
8 38 and ranking trust took the top
title in the women's division at
of the border open taking on 500 i have
three kids i'm married
i did my time in the military i own a
company i've decided i like to being
pretty and cute
trust that in an interview about
skateboarding last year so everything
that goes with that is female i love
female bodies i think it's a work of art
are you positive this is a true story
it's 100 percent of truth i thought this
is on fox news
i thought he was trying to can you
troll us but this is no that's real
that is real
listen sometimes you just want to be
pretty and cute jed you understand like
i don't want to beat the [ __ ] out of 13
year old girls that their dreams are
just crushed see this is where this
conversation has gone now now you have a
29 year old biological male
who is beating a 13 year old girl in
women's sports and we're all supposed to
sit swallow it and say oh this is the
new norm this is this is destructive
this has been uh a stain on women's
sports you now have a lot of female
athletes coming out and saying you know
they're afraid to talk they're afraid
that they're not
because they're afraid they're going to
be stigmatized they're afraid the second
they open their their mouth the media is
going to come in you know you're going
to have some article in cosmo magazine
about them and calling them a bigot and
you're anti-trans when in fact these are
girls who've worked their entire lives
they have struggled their entire lives
they've made sacrifices they've decided
not to party not to hang out with their
friends because they have a commitment
to sports they finally get to the top
and now they have to compete with a
grown man and no one's allowed to say
that it's a grown man so you have some
sports that are coming out now what was
the sport tyler we talked about the
other day that came out i don't know if
you remember and said this isn't going
to fly women swimming right okay so
swimming came out which is you know
antithetical to what's going on in
soccer finna but
right yeah i love that picture with the
guy with the sweat with the ladies
this is this went from conversation i
talk about this on my show a lot because
this went from a conversation about
acceptance of like live the life you
want do what you want to do you're an
adult you're not hurting anyone else
you're not asking anyone else to pay for
whatever you're doing great we can
support you do what you want to do to
now
in if you don't endorse this absolute
psychosis that's going on look at the
images here look at this look at that
he's huge it's no no she's huge she's
huge it's not a chinese it's a grown man
he has still has his testicles and his
he has his male parts well that's come
on man that's you guys but you just look
at the framework
these women are clearly 5'2 this guy's
six five yeah he's a swimmer and you're
supposed to say there's no advent you
know they came out a lot of a lot of the
swimmers the trans swimmers came out
said oh we don't have an advent you
don't have an advantage of course come
on we all have eyes and ears we weren't
born yesterday so what happens to all
the girls the actual women here is is
women's sports going to cease to exist
now think about it will it just be men's
sports and transports what's going to
happen here i'm serious it's a serious
question
i honestly think and we talked about
this early before i walked into it there
should be
a league just a trans league where
you call it like
dicks i don't just put every listen
whatever you're confused whatever you
guys play over here leave these little
like dude this 13 year old girl you
realize she's gonna be like her father's
gonna have to sit her down and go listen
honey you're lost to a man grow a pair
literally like you're gonna have to get
some testosterone in you and because
like it's dude it's cheating i don't
care what you say and you made a good
point nothing against that community
good i feel go do your thing but when it
comes to sports you're messing up
people's lives that little girl's that
was that's her money yeah you don't get
to deprive you get to do what you want
with your own life but you don't get to
deprive somebody else of something based
on a new set of rules that you've now
demanded that we all endorse
that's not how it works let me tell you
why this skateboarding thing is it
probably won't get as much uh tabloid
time as this for whatever reason
the the these people are at least the
same age
whether they're they got you know
whatever private parts they got going on
they're all in college okay you're 18 to
22. i get it you're talking about a 29
year old person versus a 13 year old
girl yep yeah you're talking about that
is problematic in other language a
grown-ass man yes and a young girl yes
that's exactly right
so pat you got me but you guys have kids
what do you tell your 13 year old i'm
being dead serious because i was trying
to be funny what do you tell your 13
year old daughter who just beat up a
big-ass field of people her age a 30
year old dude a 30 year old veteran that
wants to just be cute and pretty and
[ __ ] escape her words honestly what
are you two when your kid gets very
very simple for me
um
one i go speak to whoever organized it
okay and i try to use my voice to create
change that's number one and i'm gonna
go recruit other people to also say do
you feel the same way we need to have a
meeting this is not acceptable if these
parents are not happy about it i'm not
alone we got more than 50 60 i think you
have to listen to what we have to say
beautiful then if they say no then i
have to look at other places where they
can compete fairly and i will go look at
it i'm not a helpless person i will find
solutions and i'll go to a different
place it's okay when so now imagine now
when you're putting your kids in a
competition you have to ask the question
just out of curiosity such and such area
when they compete they accept
transgender competitors and they don't
just go based on what the biological
situation is what's your protocols oh no
we don't accept that okay that's great
to know then i would like my kids to
fairly compete here and if they lose
they lose if they win they win no
problem and then if at that point you're
not happy because nobody around you has
the set of values and principles that
you do then you have to make a real
serious decision with your husband and
your wife and say we have to move to a
different place that matches our values
and principles it's that simple for me
yeah it's not that complicated what
would you tell the kid what would you
tell your kid though i'm gonna have a
conversation with the kid before and say
listen i'm just oh we already have those
conversations because that conversation
is being had right now as we speak wow
and uh uh i'm straight up i explained to
them how science works i explained to
them how the values of parents and
mothers and fathers play environment
values principles confusion it's very
easy to get confused
and uh you know that's the conversation
it's a form of a bullying and in our
family we don't support bullying we're
good we don't support bullying we stand
up so good but i think i i think the the
approach is more from the standpoint of
you know when people were like i'm not
again rovi i can't believe what you're
doing
dude if you're so much for it
try to make change in the state you're
in if you can't move to another state so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]